California firefighters worked through
the night trying to stop a pair of
dangerous wildfires burning about a mile
apart the fires have forced hundreds
outside Los Angeles to leave their homes
they are now threatening to merge at
least 21 wild fires have burned more
than 130,000 acres in the hot dry West
Maria via al is in duarte California
with the fight to douse the flames but a
a good morning good morning while the
temperatures here have dialed back just
a bit it is still hot there is an
excessive heat and red flag warning
still in place right now in the last two
days these two fires have ballooned and
burned more than fifty four hundred
acres the threat is still in place which
is why 700 homes are still under
evacuation Los Angeles County Fire kept
up its relentless assault dousing the
flames from two fires that started
Monday now known as one the San Gabriel
complex fire is raging about 20 miles
northeast of Los Angeles it's extremely
hot and the fuels are ready and ripe for
combustion crew scaled this steep rugged
terrain in the foothills surrounding the
Angeles National Forest in a mission to
beat back hot spots but the county's
deputy fire chief said Tuesday
helicopters have the advantage there's a
lot of fire that we are not able to
extinguish just because the topography
and how rugged the terrain is so we're
going to be relying on aircraft more
than 130 miles to the southeast a
wildfire burning near California's
border with Mexico has exploded to more
than 6,000 acres back in duarte
firefighters said they are worried about
any shift in wind since there is plenty
of brush that hasn't burned people are
grateful to the crews were defending
their homes this is fish Canyon this is
our own this is our paradise well it
used to be this hasn't burned since 1980
these two fires have not yet been
combined right now they are only at ten
percent contained officials here are
telling residents they need to have a
bag packed and ready to go because if
those winds shift it could be a problem
later on down the line Gail Maria thank
you